I loved the first Pacific Rim and that
classic tale of robots and monsters that
hold weights in that holds power I grew
up watching the old giant monster movies
from Japan the classics like ultraman
space giants and of course godzilla i
just ate it up
everybody has felt that fleeting when
those monsters go through a city
it creates an instant excitement with
the technology we have we have a chance
to make it that much more spectacular no
te karere
anzo cohen economist Aniceto science a
chinkara Matta and Marco and Steiner
tamata camba
and of course tomorrow to collect it
coitus ultimately it's a world conflict
and everyone's put aside their
differences and come together many you
enter this program you join a family we
stand together that's what makes us
strong
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference
I'll help me save the world Pacific Rim
uprising gives an answer back to those
monsters that we've grown up watching if
they were to attack us what would we
have we have the Eggers the fight
sequences are different than in any
other movie I've ever done you're
plugged in and you're along for the ride
[Music]
Amara built scrapper
she's committed her whole life to this
Jaeger there's things about the kaiju
that we've never seen before it's just
epic
I've had announced that this is the most
action I've ever done
is like getting a ticket to the best
books in my Shepard
[Music]
we were born into a world at war between
the monsters who had destroyed our
cities and the monsters we created to
stop them we thought we had sacrificed
enough but the wall we thought we
finished is just beginning and the only
thing standing in front of the
apocalypse
is us
but it doesn't matter where you came
from we believed in you and who didn't
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference
let's get it done
drum of war
the love drop
they evolve
[Music]
there's something you need to see
well he's pretty bad
[Music]
by everything you got
[Music]
ditto
[Music]